[Music]
let's go to chelsea in kansas city
missouri what's up kansas city chelsea
how are we doing
great john how are you cool go chiefs
right
yeah go chiefs they killed it this
weekend yeah they did pima homes he's a
red raider
awesome all right so what's up
so
last year i divorced my best friend
um why'd you do that
well
we got married twice this was a second
round we're just much better friends
than we are
married people
okay
and that happens sometimes and so i came
to terms with that but
i filed for divorce in january of 2020
after a very hard we were in marriage
counseling all of 2019. and
it got to the point where every council
was like well you just need to change
who you are
to me
and i'm like okay so i try and i try and
i try but
nothing i did even to the point of
allowing him to quit his job in february
of 19 to stay home with the kids
it still wasn't enough
so we filed in january of 2020
covet hit in march
so he's home and the kids are home and
i'm still working full-time at home
and you're divorced two months
i'm divorced now yeah our divorce was
finalized in may
um we'd also put our house on the market
in january of 2020
and i couldn't live in that chaos
anymore so i moved out in may the house
closed and sold in july
and the kids and i moved to an apartment
and then he had moved in with my parents
at the time because he didn't have a job
now he lives on his own everything's
great but every year around this time
my kids bring up our old house and how
much they miss it and
i can't help but feel like i've
failed them
and just constantly feel like a failure
because i did work so hard
to keep her house
when he quit his job but
kovid really made me realize how much i
missed my kids
and being home with them
and
i wasn't willing to be the only one
working
in the home anymore but now i find
myself
struggling this year
feeling so badly that
what if we could have worked it out even
though we had tried it twice
we're still like
i mean
last christmas we went down to branson
together
as a
group
and we get along really well
but
we're just so on different spectrums as
far as hard work goes that
if we set goals we have to stick to them
and he just was never willing to do that
so
so
a home is a metaphor home's not a place
home is a fantasy for y'all
and when your kids say they miss the
house
they miss the home
they miss
that picture they have
and it doesn't sound like anybody's
grieved the loss
of your marriage of your friendship it
sounds like y'all are still playing
friend you're still playing married-ish
sort of kind of
and nobody has said
this happened
this was devastating this was
heartbroken i missed the house too
i miss being married to my best friend
too
and yet here we are
i started doing that a lot the last
couple months and i'm in a new
relationship now
where
we were having some fights
a few months ago and i'm like i really
think this is on me
because i haven't greased the loss and
so i kind of feel like i'm in limbo
but it's affecting every part of my life
and i've gone to counseling and
everybody's like
well
this is all on him like you just need to
get over it and think better of yourself
it it
he could have been the most evil abusive
angry
awful person
and you still grieve that loss
you grieve the loss of trust in yourself
you grieve the loss of trust in your
marriage you grieve the fact that your
kids don't have a dad present anymore
you grieve all those things
and so the fact that he
is a good human being you just couldn't
you just decided i can't live with him
anymore you gotta you gotta grieve that
doesn't grieving isn't about whose fault
it was
grieving is simply acknowledging the gap
between what i hoped for and what
actually happened
and you married this guy twice thinking
he was it
and you chose for him not to be
and so you're going to grieve that gap
it's not about finding fault and blame
and getting over stuff now man
but you're right it will affect every
relationship forward because you don't
trust yourself anymore
you don't trust yourself to stick out it
when you stick it out when it gets hard
you don't trust yourself to pick right
you don't trust yourself you just don't
trust yourself that's what grief's for
it's making peace with reality
so i guess my big question is how do i
show my kids
in future relationships that a marriage
can work
especially when the question comes up
with
well you and daddy get along but why why
couldn't you stay married and how am i
supposed to stay married like how do i
show them what a good relationship and
that when you get married it is for good
better or worse
but it was i don't want to raise that i
know and i don't want to raise them to
think that you can just
quit if it gets hard you just quit and i
that's what i feel like i did
well then the only thing you can do if
you want to teach them that lesson is to
teach them out of your
out of the things that you did wrong
that you feel like you did wrong
see what i'm saying you want you want
your kids to have a great marriage show
them what a great marriage looks like
and
you're there's not a lot you can tell
them right now because they've
experienced it they felt it they've seen
it
and so if you get remarried to somebody
they will see what a good marriage looks
like 5 10 15 20 years later from now
oh
this is it
but there's not like gonna be some magic
conversation you have like by the way i
did this and this and this and i feel
like i did it like this that's not how
it really works it really works like
that the kids can't process that how old
are your kids
my daughter is seven and my son is three
yeah
i mean
that's when your kids say i really miss
the house and you hold them tight and
you cry and you say i miss it too
i really miss it too
and we miss daddy and you say i miss him
too
and then they say well then why don't we
just go why does the daddy just come
back here
you say cause you know it's funny they
never i was really afraid last year when
we all went on vacation and we had to go
to two separate homes that they would be
like well why can't we all stay together
not even they didn't even question it
they will sometimes just like this is
the way but maybe this is the way life
is yeah and you got to remember that
they don't have that back they're just
trying to deal with whatever reality's
put in front of them that's what kids do
that's the beauty of being a kid and
that is the
that's why being a kid is so brutal
because they just deal with the reality
and put in front of them
huge chances
you you haven't made peace with this
you are still
you haven't owned this
i feel like i've cried about the loss
recently and i'm just
like
when is it enough and i'm in a
relationship now where
now i'm like
we're living as if we
are married we should get married but
then i don't want to rush into a
marriage again just because
life
looks like we should be married jesse
you're
chelsea you're still married
you're still married to that dude
you still love that guy you still call
him your best friend
you don't live in the same house with
him you have a separate life than him
but y'all are still teaching marriage
would be great right now
exactly
you're playing married you want both
sides of this you want to be divorced
and have the freedom to be with other
people and you want to
not have to live with the reality that i
am divorced
i left him because we could he couldn't
keep goals up or he would whatever the
thing the reasons you left him that's a
whole other call
but you have not separated yourself from
that
relationship have a legal separation
but you're still
you haven't let that go
and you've got no business dragging some
other poor soul into this until you've
let that go
it's like a weird inverted affair kind
of
am i right
i feel like i've i have let it go but i
never did the grieving process you are
right about that
i
know
for a fact i never want to marry him
again
but we're still really good friends
and you can be really good friends but
you need to be best friends with your
new spouse
and when something funny happens or
something sad happens or something great
happens
your first call needs to be to your new
husband
not to your
ex and i don't think you're there yet
it's like somebody died and you still
pick up the phone to call them when
something happens you haven't fully your
body hasn't accepted this is over
that's what i'm saying
i think it's hard with oh it's real hard
it is
but what i'm telling you is even harder
is dealing with kids who are living in
that limbo and they are
this has been a weird summer campy awful
weird vacationy
thing
i don't know if you've ever been
swimming in the ocean in the middle of
the night
it's both exhilarating and terrifying
because it's just ink black for as far
as you can see
and you're bobbing
with the waves and you can see your
friends around you
but it's also you don't know what's
underneath you you know what's above you
you don't know
what's really happening and that's where
your kids are
they deserve the closure you deserve the
closure your ex-husband deserves the
closure
you gotta grieve it you gotta spend a
season where you don't talk to him
except to drop the kids off you gotta
spend a season where you don't call each
other or text each other you have to
spend a season forgiving yourself or
making peace with yourself you've got to
spend a season saying this part of my
life is over
then we will rebuild a new friendship
because we have to co-parent these kids
and we're going to love our kids
whatever he does can't live at your
parents house anymore he needs to go
have his own life
create his own world and if he chooses
to be homeless that's his choice and if
he chooses to not want to work those are
all his choices now
he's an adult male he gets to do that
but you've got to spend some a season
breaking that relationship off and you
haven't done that yet
because you still want to hang on to it
the good parts of it
you gotta let it go
you can rebuild it later but right now
you gotta let it go
thanks for that call chelsea